here's my question Brian
this is like a four-line proof
the only way out of this conundrum
assume that it's three percent odds
assume that you're playing Roulette in
either a European wheel or an American
wheel I guess the American wheel has two
green yeah zero zero and zero and the
Europeans have one and otherwise there's
something like 36 red and and black
things okay assume that that's the case
how many times do you get to spin this
thing before it comes up green
no one knows and not that many
yes it's unlikely but you can't keep
playing this game
all right that's the first thing next
question is if that's true
give me the total list of Escape
scenarios like one thing that you may
not know that I I only know because I've
recently uh found myself in circles of
people who have 10 figures and up
is that a lot of very rich people are
thinking about personal escapes from
Armageddon
they're not thinking about the bunkers
or yeah bunkers different countries
Yachts whatever
okay this is ridiculous I mean for only
only in limited situations is that a
great plan
the the
there's only one thing to do which is to
ask
how do we get ourselves diversification
so that as you point out these conserved
features of collapsing civilizations
don't take down the permanent human
Enterprise
and that's why you know I'm going to a
Bitcoin conference in Miami
um and I think that the talk is supposed
to be they usually say fix the money fix
the world and I think I have a change to
fix the money leave the world
um the importance of decentralization in
space fairing uh if Bitcoin is a
protocol how does it work if you're
multi-planetary uh if you're in
different star systems or your kardashef
three or infinite free energy right yeah
or do you have a different situation
whereby the point of Bitcoin is to start
working on a decentralized option like
from decentralization to
decentralization the key point of
failure
is that we're all sharing one
terrestrial surface now Bezos or Bezos I
don't know how to pronounce this last
name talks about like Gerald k O'Neill
cylinders and maybe Stanford uh Tori
where you get artificial gravity through
centripetal acceleration
um Elon is focused on the moon not quite
sure what Branson is doing but the point
is all of these people at least have the
nub of the ID we've got to diversify
and with all that money
I don't ever want to hear about a
theoretical physicist
who isn't putting three kids through uh
private schools with a second home a
pension secured and the ability to check
into any Four Seasons anywhere on the
planet Earth I mean this is obscene the
only people who can save us are
mathematicians and physicists
and we don't know that it's possible
it's quite possible that they could
return a final Theory
and we could look at it and say yep
Einstein was right the final Theory
doesn't contain any new options that the
one faster I don't like travel don't no
we don't know and until we know and
until we hold the conferences we're
stead instead held hostage to an
economic system that is is mostly there
to protect people born in like the 1940s
and 50s so that they can live out their
days pretending that they're doing
physics while they do geometric
um analysis inspired by physics which
they might call String Theory or
topological Quantum field Theory or toy
models or conformal field Theory it's
like no
it's now time to get back to physics
it's now time to do what Old Stone
Pocono and Shelter Island did as
conferences which is to reignite the
physics Community get the smart people
in here and here's the dumbest thing I
and I'm just embarrassed to say it but
here goes
physics built your entire economy more
or less suitably understood from biotech
to Communications to the World Wide Web
to the semiconductor the dumbest thing
in the world is money or tokens
go get us a huge pile drop it off and go
away
[Music]